two characters one room one movie any
tips or lessons you can share so yeah
approaching a two person one room film
should should essentially be the same
approach you take in any other film I
personally approached I personally take
is to treat all of my films like action
films because I you know my personal
opinion is that actions films and
westerns are essentially their last true
genres in my eyes I mean those are the
two genres that know exactly what
they're there to do and they attempt to
deliver it every time you know some of
the best action films that you can think
of always deliver and they do that
because not necessarily because they're
you know people are you know people do
like action more but they deliver
because they don't try to all the time
they don't try to stretch what they're
there to do they know that ultimately
they're there to entertain you and then
the best action films that want to stand
the test of time the diehards The Matrix
films like that those films you know
they layer on a little something
different they layer on since a level of
sophistication or approach and and
that's what makes them interesting so
that's the way I kind of approach my
films the same way or I try to treat all
my films as action films so how does
that relate to a two person one room
film I mean you still need the same
elements right you still need you you
know your inciting incident your act
breaks your main point etcetera etc etc
you still need all of those things but
my sort of big developments and sort of
action scenes so to speak are in
increase in pace or silence are my
weapons right so words are my weapons
and the way that I paced and placed them
in the film is kind of how I would
dictate my action scenes and that's kind
of a larger picture point of view but
like a more inside point of view is that
it's essentially the same thing if you
don't have the right story you know they
may be right says story story story if
you don't have the right story you're in
trouble if you don't
the right if you don't understand the
story and understand the dramatic breaks
in the story you're in trouble if you
don't have the right story beats you're
in trouble so it's it's the approach is
no different right when you're outlining
your hope you know well everybody
doesn't online but when I'm outlining
the film the approach is the same as if
I had 20 characters I mean you have to
get from point A to point B and there's
a there's a tried-and-true
sort of structure that helps you get
there and get and get there efficiently
so that's you know I try to approach it
the same way that I approach any other
film that I do um you know you know some
of the ways that I try to go about that
is understanding what it is I'm trying
to do you know when you when you're
writing when you're writing especially
when you're when you learn screenwriting
from you get taught screenwriting one of
the big things they tell you is to get
in a scene and get out of the scene
right and that's just very good advice
you know the audience already knows
where you're going before you get there
anyway so there's no point in hanging
out to get in there and get out of there
you know I mean especially if you don't
have anything extremely interesting to
say just keep moving and and essentially
what they're telling you is you when
you're writing a two-minute piece you
have to understand sort of the
philosophy of what the screenwriting
which is essentially when they tell you
to to get in and out of a scene because
the audience knows where you're going
before you get there essentially what
they're telling you is is to move and be
interesting move and be interesting over
be interesting and that sort of mantra
should be running in your head when
you're writing anyway but we you know
you can't when you're writing a two-man
film sort of the set up the midpoint and
delivery are all have to be based on the
conversation and how you how you keep
that interesting how you move from one
scene to the next a lot of times you can
use direction in your writing to get
from one scene to the next you can have
characters move or have them do
something or pick
something that that implies that we're
moving on to the next scene and that
gives the audience a visual cue in a
visual understanding that the plot and
the movie is still moving forward
you know you still have to deploy sort
of the same tactics that you would any
other time which is when you're writing
a two-minute piece I utilize even though
characters are talking way more then
probably you've ever written before I
stood you till eyes other techniques to
keep it interesting and to keep it
moving I utilize pacing
you know sometimes characters will speak
a lot and then sometimes they'll say one
word sometimes they won't speak
sometimes one character will do all the
talking the other one the other won't
say anything sometimes they'll be you'll
talk over each other and that's using
that pacing and dialogue helps keep keep
things interesting so again it goes all
the way back to what I originally spoke
about which was treating every film like
an action film and you know in when you
thinking about a two two person film you
know for me the the shootouts and the in
the explosions are words and pacing
sometimes there's a rapid fire exchange
between two people sometimes one
character is just sort of mowing down
the enemy like if you think of like a
terminator tooth when Otto Schwartz and
Edgar kind of knocks the window out and
you just mows down all these cops and
you know it's a big action set piece but
sometimes I'll have a character do that
with words and speak and speak rapidly
and quickly and speak over someone and
not let them speak and then sometimes
boom I'll drop a big bomb and you know
you in a character will be emphatic
about something and then you let the
scene breathing that the characters
understand the importance of what just
happened and you know that's sort of
that goes back to again back so really
sort of basic elements how the
characters feel tells the audience how
they feel if the characters care then
you know you have a greater chance of
the audience caring if the characters
don't care about what's going on then
you know there's a greater chance that
you'll fail it'll be you know the story
will fail because there's no the stakes
the stakes aren't there you know so you
even though it sounds daunting it's
still the same approach you just
kind of go about it the the execution
changes and you know I think it'll help
you as a writer if you if you try to do
it you know um you know I don't know you
know other people might not have any
interest in doing it but I think it
would help you as a writer if you try to
do it and you know it comes with it
really comes with one big inherent
pitfall which is you know it is baked
into it which is two people talking is
inherently boring right and the longer
you look at it isn't the more boring it
becomes so you know you always hear show
don't tell show don't tell show don't
tell well you you know everything is
everything needs to be kept in context
right um if you if you can show it and
not tell it you should probably do it
but there are times when it's
interesting to hear a character talk his
or her way through something or hear two
people go back and forth to come up with
an idea and you think of like Ocean's
eleven right there's scenes where Brad
Pitt and George Clooney kind of go back
they kind of go back and forth and it's
fun and it's in this kind of you know
light but they come up with one idea so
they go back in there and they go back
and forth and talk about something
unrelated or one person talks and then
Brad people and say were and George
Clooney will come up with come up with
the idea on his own and it'll he'll
think he had a conversation with Brad
Pitt and you didn't like sometimes that
can be fun sometimes it can be
interesting so you know no rule is set
in stone um writing for two people can
be fun it can also be daunting I I sort
of changed my dialogue approach and I
kind of I try to tailor it to films you
know something I kind of walk into a
film knowing that people talk a lot in
this movie or you know this is a more
traditional sort of tried and true
straightforward kind of film were you
know show it on tell so um you know I
think it's fun I think it's fun I like
it and I can also see why it would not
be of interest to someone else any other
writer but um you know it's it's it's
it's it's a fun exercise if you if you
if you have the time I would suggest you
try it
simply because it'll help you learn to
not she and also learn to use your words
more importantly even though characters
talk a lot in the film still every
single word has to have a point and move
the film incrementally forward every
single word not not every single
sentence every single word has to move
the film incremental T forward and that
is something that you you know you can't
you can't cheat when it comes to a
two-man film you can't just blow up
something when you want when you when
you when you feel like oh let's spend 10
minutes I can't keep people's attention
for 10 minutes and I'll just blow
something up well and now you have to
you have to keep people's attention for
10 minutes so you know I think it would
help you become help someone become a
better writer I
I've learned I've written more than one
to two two men films and I enjoy I liked
muscies me and it frees me up at the
same time so it's it's a weird way of
looking at it but it's still it's still
fun
you